et et Gille tu nous traites tu nous
traites très souvent de gros fachot mais
si tu voulais lutter contre les idées du
Front national c'est justement en
supprimant ce genre d'aide que que tu
pourrais lutter contre le Front national
parce que si les gens votent pour le
Front national c'est parce que les gens
ne supportent plus qu'il y ait des aides
qui soient donné à ceux qui ne font rien
au détriment de ceux qui travaillent
sans e et qui qui qui qui qui ne vivent
plus la fin du mois donc voilà si tu
veux lutter contre le frond national
supprime ce genre d'aide mais moi
j'entends parfaitement ce que dit cyil
mais à à sa question je rép non on ne
doit pas privilégier les Français vous
dites s entendu c'est les Français
qui travaillent par rapport à des
étrangers tous les autres pays chez nous
dans tous les aut pay les a pays en
Europe on privilégie les citoyens du
pays même dans tous les pays
grosot que tu réponds je mtiens je
maintiens que 1 milliard pour 4 pas ça
je ne veux pas qu'on supprime pas du
tout je ne veux pas qu'on suppre C donc
c'est clair je réponds à votre question
non on ne doit pas donner plus au
français qui travaillent non non qu
raison c'est des raisons éthiques
idéologies tu dois donner plus au tu la
tu laissesever des mecs qui travill
pasever des
étrangersgul tu fais
quue à le donner un milliard d' on peut
très bien sur notre budget C je par mais
je te parle pas que de ça ça tu veux
bien j'ai fait une tir de 10 minutes
pour
dire j'ai parfait lu expliquer s'il te
plaît vraiment vraiment voilà a raison
quand tu restes sur l'axe de d'Eric
sooti de Monsieur siotti 1500 pour les
agriculteurs c'est des Mago il s'est
réveillé ce matin ah des agriculteurs ah
bah je vais leur donner 1500 ça c'est
pour faire plaisir à la politique
maintenant moi je suis comme toi je veux
que l'aide elle reste mais je prends
l'axe de Radouan tu l'aide tu la donnes
en cas de force majeur en cas de grave
maladie il faut penser aux Français qui
aujourd'hui travaillent tous les matins
qui se lèvent mais qui peuvent pas vivre
de leur propre travail ça veut dire avec
les crèches les machins les les les tout
ce qu'il doivent payer les taxes
d'habitation
les taxes l'essence tout ce qu'il y a à
payer l'électricité à la fin ils vont
travailler dans le vide par rapport au
voisin qui lui a touché plein d'aide et
qui va faire 100 100 mais encore des AES
qui sera pas imposé et qui per à rien
pourtant l'argent qu'on lui donne les
100 et les 1008 c'est des vrais billets
et lui n'est pas imposé comme le voisin
qui se lève à 5h pour aller courir après
un r comment tu vas expliquer ça aux
gens pendant des années c'est
insupportable il y a Mickey Willis qui
dit g verd est dans un monde de
bisounours bravo Mickey il vient ils
viennent surtout pour ça même si ce
n'est pas tout le tous les R SS mais
c'est parce que la France donne trop et
oublie ses artisans ses agriculteurs ces
PME qui se lèvent tôt et qui se lèv pour
faire tourner ce pays merci cyil Hanouna
qu'est-ce que tu réponds pas l'un contre
l'autre C c'est pas l'un contre l'autre
je vous le répond
à on pas dit que c'était l'un contre
l'autre verd tu crois tu crois que tu es
où tu crois que tu es où CIS te rends
compte dans laquelle dans la situation
dans laquelle est la France aujourd'hui
mais tu te vis dans quel monde tu vis où
excuse-moi tu S mais la politique c'est
des choix ah donc vous choisissez de
laisser mourir des étrangers mour la pas
mourir tu habites où dans quel pays ici
en France je tu vois tu vois la
situation de la France tu crois que la
France est fier de toi non pas pour moi
moi je suis pas fier de toi en tout cas
ou l'argumentaire typique du mec qui ne
sort jamais du 7è
arrondis y a aucun problème où tu
habites et tu penses que c'est une
généralité dans un pays dans lequel il a
3 des personnes qui n'ont pas leur
pièces d'enté qui n'ont pas qui n'ont
pas accès au soins ces gens-l ils
crèvent ces gensl n'ont pas accès à
l'aide médicale d'urgence et c'est pas
une honte de faire une hiérarchie
d'abord les travailleurs les Français et
ensuite peut-être si on a encore un peu
d'argent les étrangers si on a encore un
peu
d'argent vous laiss mourir les
étrangers commenc par les
par ailleurs par exemple
agriculteurs ils ont travailleurs saison
qui sont régul qui font même venir et
qui font même venir du Magreb Gilles
Verdez inadmissible d'entendre que Gill
ne veut pas donner à ceux qui
travaillent surtout nos propres citoyens
les agriculteurs crèvent et ils s'en
fout les Français travaillent pour payer
les aides voilà en fait non on peut plus
on peut plus aider tout le monde
voilà alors un autre un autre mais je
pas le l tu le dis à une fois de plus on
dit les agriculteurs c'est vrai que là
ils sont dans lactue mais c'est pas les
agriculteurs les mecs c'est les
restaurateurs c'est les boulangers c'est
un mec qui un mec qui fait de
l'événementiel c'est tout le système
tout le système du coupt du travail en
France et moi vous me faites rire ce
qu'à chaque fois dans les débats partout
même j'entends la télé regardez comment
ça se passe en Allemagne regardez
comment ça se passe là-bas mais le
travail là-bas allez voir c'est moins
cher c'est moins cher qu'ici on est les
plus imposés au niveau du travail la
France est champion en Allemagne ils pas
autant il pas autant et le travail dans
aucun autre pays donc je t'explique
g tout ce que tu dis du début à la fin
dans cette émission c'est de la merde
c'est non non non oui oui oui mais non
mais tout ce que tu dis j ver tout ce
que tu dis ce sont des choses qui ont
déjà été faites et qui n'ont pas
marchéess tout ce que tu dis Gill Vernez
tu as l'image de la France que je ne
connaissais pas des années 70 à mon avis
tu vois ou avant voilà quand ou 80 voilà
où c'était voilà je sais pas même avant
exactement mais Gill Verz en fait le
problème qu'il a c'est que tu es resté
bloqué euh quand tu avais 20 ans ou je
sais pas 18 mais c'est un utopiste c'est
bien ex c'est un utopiste mais un moment
les utopistes ça t'envoie que dans le
mur et Gil Verdez je t'explique tu sais
pourquoi pourquoi je m'énerve avec toi
tous les soirs parce que justement tu
représentes un courant qui nous envoie
dans le mur tu nous tu représentes des
gens qui pensent tout savoir qui pensent
avoir raison qui pensent qui peuvent
aider tout le monde des gens qui font
pas de choix et je vais te dire le
problème que tu as aujourd'hui j'ai
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la France c'est pas
la France des années 70 la France tous
les ans elle décline tu fait des années
qu'elle décline la France on dit qu'on
est 7e puissance économique je pense moi
je te le dis dans 2 ans on passe on
passe on passe on est plus top 10 voilà
je te le dis et je je je suis sûr et
certain parce qu'il y a beaucoup il y a
des pays qui vont nous passer devant
donc Gilles Vernez ma faute quand même
si c'est ta faute moi c'est ta faute
parce que c'est des
g des gens comme toi tu veux te dis qui
qui qui empêche qui empêche les gens de
dire ce qu'ils pensent qui empêche les
gens de prendre des décisions et de
prendre les bonnes décision parce que
c'est des gens comme toi qui paralysent
le pays tu VO dis oui mais je le pense
vraiment je pense que tu fais partie des
gens qui paralyse les pays et les gens
que tu représentes et les gens et le
courant que tu représentes le courant et
ne me dis pas parce que c'est le courant
W voilà tout ça je t'explique ça c'est
ce qui mène le pays dans le mur et Gill
Verdez tu es responsable parce que mais
c'est pas toi mais je te dis pourquoi je
m'énerve après toi parce que je pense
que tu es tu es un peu le porte-parole
dans cette émission de ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui le pays est paralysé il
est paralysé à cause de gens comme toi
voilà je te le dis et je et je pense que
je suis pas le seul à le penser je sais
pas qui pense comme moi ici autour de la
table mais je pense qu'ils sont nombreux
vous je sais pas si vous vous souvenez
on avait reçu un monsieur il y a
quelques semaines qui ne pouvait plus se
payer son médicament je crois ilil avait
un concer du poumon euh il avait donc
retraité il avait cotisé toute sa vie et
il ne pouvait pas se payer il arrêté son
traitement euh évidemment avec les risqu
que ça comporte qu'est-ce que tu dirais
à ce monsieur quand on sait que un
étranger en situation irrégulière qui
arrive sur le territoire peut se payer
des lunettes si on a besoin ça été
dérembboursé c'est c'est autre chose tu
a le même discours que matide Panau ils
ne veulent pas la réussite de la France
et des Français ti voilà j'ai pas
entendu pens écoute moi ce que j'en
pense Cyril entre euh on est d'une
génération où on avait jamais vu nous
par exemple des étudiants SDF ça
n'existait pas aujourd'hui ça l'ai
aujourd'hui les les étudiants
euh les hôpitaux qui brûlent au plus
vite que que que Notre-Dame de Paris
c'est juste un scandale donc pour le
coup ce que disais en plus tu m'as tu
m'as retiré cette phrase Géraldine c'est
que déshabiller Paul pour habiller
Jacques c'est totalement ça moi je suis
en train de juste je pose une question
répondez-moi parce que moi je suis pas
pas un politique les agriculteurs les
étudiants les hôpitaux qui sont dans un
état déplorable d'ailleurs il y a un
gamin qui vient de mourir au bout de 8h
est-ce que c'est la faute des
étrangers non c'est
pas ça n' rien à voir peux pas poser la
question comme ça parce que en fait tu
ne poses la question est mal posée on
peut pas on peut pas te répondre à ça
bien sûr qu'on va te dire non mais c'est
pas ça qu'on est en train de dire ce
qu'on est en train de te dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la France continuer comme
ça en fait comme ça un moment un moment
un pays c'est comme je vais dire la
France c'est comme une entreprise c'est
comme un budget familial ou un moment si
tu dis tu as 5 enfants et que tu dis bah
tiens j'ai j'ai 1000 € de budget pour
acheter des cadeaux de Noël et que tu
donnes 800 € pour ton premier enfant et
que tu dis bah après il va me rester 200
pour les quatre autres forcément il y en
a un qui va être privilégié qui va avoir
un plus beau cadeau que les autres un
moment mais un moment la France
aujourd'hui on peut pas gagner 5 fois
200 parce qu'aujourd'hui on les a pas
c'est-à-dire qu'aujourd'hui euh c'est 5
x 200 ça suffira pas puisque les je vais
te dire le problème qu'il y a les
problèmes sont si importants dans tous
les secteurs que tu as donné c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on n' pas assez déjà pour
ces secteurslà et il faut couper à un
moment des choses donc à moment il faut
savoir quoi couper à un moment alors
après comme a dit Raymond moi je je me
dis aussi euh Raymond a raison et un
moment ils ont ils ont sorti le PGE
pendant le le covid donc ils ont sorti
de l'argent ils ont prêté de l'argent
bon après tous ceux qui ont pr PGE
aujourd'hui mer
e
Toutant plus catastropique donc il y en
a énormément qui vont planter le PGE je
vous dis aussi parce queils peuvent pas
et donc ça encore ça va faire un trou je
peux vous dire dans la cagnotte trou
d'unétat qui va être énorme parce que le
PGE il y en a énormément qui peuvent pas
le payer et qui se retrouent aujourd'hui
qui disent B non on peut pas le payer on
va planter donc on va planter ils vont
tout planter donc il c'est pas de le fa
aujourd'hui étr pour les pour dire av
pour covid ils avent trouvéormément
d'arg ce que dit Raymon je comprends il
dit est-ce que il y a deux solutions
c'est où tu sors la planche habillée
mais derrière en dette ça va te coûter
énormément et la dette de la France
aujourd'hui on peut peut plus se
permettre mais tu sors la planche
habillée et tu dis bah tu sais quoi et
ben on va aider les gens et on va sortir
je sais pas tant de milliards mais
derrière je peux te dire que tu vas voir
les impôts tu vas les sentir passer et
quoi qu'il arrive que tu vas te donner
d'un côté tu vas le rendre de l'autre
voilà ou bien euh tu as tu as pas 36
solutions ou bien tu dis aujourd'hui je
dois couper euh des des des des des des
des budgets qui sont allouer à des
choses qui sont il faut que je fasse des
choix comme une entreprise exactement
mais aujourd'hui g Verdes toi le
problème que tu as c'est que tu es nul
en économie voilà oui non je pense voilà
il a dit
merci voilà non mais je pense je sais
pas comment tu géres ton budget chez toi
mais ça doit être catastrophique tu as
un peu d'argent de côté bah j'essaie oui
de gérer normalement quoi ouais
responsable quoi j'ess mais g je tadore
mon ché mais je te dis la
vérité tu vois bien tu vois bien qu'il y
a un problème dans ce que tu dis mon
chéri tu vois bien tu vois bien que ta
culture W et ton progressisme ne vont
pas avec la société d'aujourd'hui oui
Gill tu connais l'histoire sais très
bien que l'histoire est faite de choix
et quand on fait pas de choix c'est ce
qui s'est passé avant la seconde guerre
mondial on a toujours voulu sauvegarder
on faisait semblant de pas voir
l'Allemagne qui est en train de se
réarmer d'attaquer progressivement les
pays limitrophes et cetera et les
historiens disent à force de vouloir
absolument sauver la paix on a rendu la
guerre inévitable et là tu es en train
de faire la même chose toi à force de
vouloir faire p à tout le monde en en
train de transformer la France en une
poudrière qui va finir par exploser
parce que les gens en ont marre de qu'on
fasse pas des choix et qu'on va faire
plaisir à tout le monde là qu'on a pas
les moyens par du gamin il a un instant
qui est décé sachez que dans l'émission
de ce weekend on aura un proche qui nous
racontera exactement ce qui s'est passé
et vous allez voir ce qui est devenu la
France et aujourd'hui quand il y a des
des des gamins qui qui meurent aux
urgences Gil verd bien sûr ce n'est pas
de ta faute c'est pas la faute de
personne comme on dit mais aujourd'hui
vous allez voir ce qui est devenu la
France et ça c'est une mort qu'on aurait
pu éviter vous verrez le témoignage sera
très fort ce sera ce weekend dans
l'émission du weekend oui qu'est-ce que
vous vouleez répondre Jean-Michel en
fait il nous parle d'histoire mais
l'histoire de la France c'est une
histoire d'ouverture c'est une histoire
d'accueil et là vous la réduisez pe plus
on peut plus on n peut plus de
l'histoire on t'a dit il y a 2 secondes
que tu étais que tu étais que tu étais
anachronique
Anachron vous incarnez c'est la
préférence
nationale
non parce que regarde moi moi je vais
t'exli moi j'incarne pas spécialement la
préférence nationale mais je vais
t'expliquer déjà pour l'écriture tu veux
tout changer tu veux changer l'histoire
et là tu veux pas changer l'histoire
l'histoire il faut la changer à un
moment donné tu peux pas rester sur ce
qu'on avait quand on avait des milliards
moi je vais te dire à un moment donné
tout comme toi je veux qu'on soigne un
étranger à partir du moment que tu l'as
laissé rentrer sur le territoire il faut
le soigner tu l'as laissé rentrer il est
là tu en cas d'urgenence mais moi je
vais même plus loin parce que vous
parlez restez bloqué sur le truc et je
rejoins cyil quand il dit faut trouver
de l'argent moi celui qui a jamais bossé
en France qui a deux bras qui a deux
jambes qui passe toutes ses journées au
café en bas et qui touche ses
allocations pour gratter moi
je une fois plusas rien
é r é ce que j'ai paras Ren éc par que
c'est exactement ce que second j'ai la
France des assist on veut plus on parle
pas des étrangers ou pas étrangers par
on parle pas d'étranger quel qu'il soit
par la France comme il a dit le gars le
gars qui va faire des vidéos sur insta
et qui dit regardez moi les gars avec
les Z salut les
louends
3000 € mais le me tuas vu les vidéos me
prend 3000
toute la journée qui vont cratter des
billets bingo ou de millionnaire ou de
black ou de Vegas là je peux te dire ça
ça c'est ta France c'est pas ma France
tu veux que je te dis Mo il
raisonulatum
jeum c'est l'argent
donne
est valide pe travailler et qui fait
tout pour pas travailler
ilit non ça ça me PLA pas non ça j'ai
pasé sais pouroi parce que va trer on va
lui proposer00 € net et reste chez
[Applaudissements]
luialement ona et sachez que je viens de
recevoir un